you are such an inspiration to so many
people for just how you use your
platform and your voice despite a
positive healthy just body image where
to buy that power come from I think I've
definitely struggled with my own body
image for so long for so many years
especially growing up in the public eye
and having my own personal struggles
with it that I kind of learned to cope
and move on and deal with the issues and
kind of change the way I feel about it
but I really had the greatest
opportunity to have some wonderful role
models especially Sofia Vergara for me
you know working with a curvy beautiful
woman that everybody looked up to so
it's really nice to see that and for me
that was kind of like my inspiration to
the board and accept myself because
that's what matters you're killing the
Instagram game anything that we won't
see you posed by aliens just having fun
you know I like my fans to see what I'm
doing and hanging out everybody's like
so hyped up on the fact that like I post
photos for my bus out it's what everyone
has a but you know I don't think it's
like I don't think it's crazy I get so
confused so I could will make it such a
big deal it's like let me live I'm
enjoying my life you're enjoying your
life you should be posting your butt if
you like it too very funny the end of
the comment section to relay their
opinion I have my opinion and that's
what it is I'm not gonna fight with
someone on my Instagram that like tells
me they don't like my outfit or I should
put my butt away okay I'm sorry that you
think I should put my butt away but just
unfollow me I have to ask you I saw a
certain sterling Bowman here with you
we've been best friends for 10 years we
are not dating are you dating anyone are
you looking for that I'm single I mean
I'm open I'm open to meeting anybody I'm
just kind of like been single for a
little while now I've enjoyed it and if
something happens to nothing
you